christian the nevada hospital
association reports that
unvaccinated patients are putting a
strain on our health care system
remember the surge in covet 19 cases and
hospitalizations last summer
the state is reporting that our levels
right now are worse than that
so what that means for hospitals
overcrowding and staffing shortages
and some surgeries being postponed why
is this
patients who have refused to get
vaccinated are taking up resources
governor steve siselek said thursday the
delta variant is spreading like wildfire
and almost all of the nevadans who have
died of covid19 this year
have not been vaccinated the nevada
hospital association reports that 31
percent of patients in intensive care
units are suffering from covid19
five hospitals here are reporting
staffing shortages
i asked about hospital levels during
today's virtual briefing
it is something that is we are
constantly
trying to stress that this is very real
um and that we
always need to be you know working to
get more people vaccinated because
if we don't we know what the future
holds we are seeing in other states
right now
it could be a very very serious reality
for nevada in the near future
if we don't prevent folks from getting
in there in the first place
chief of staff michelle white points out
it is very rare for a
vaccinated individual to end up in the
hospital with
covid19 in clark county right now about
47 percent of people
eligible for the vaccine have received
it and in areas where workers are
canvassing and doing outreach
the state reports they are seeing an
increase in
vaccinations